واا الى التطورات في القدس كما تبعنا
واياكم قبل قليل الصور الاوليه اذا
الصور الاوليه الى كما ذكرنا واياكم ل همم
هذه العمليه عمليه اطلاق النار التي تمت
في بلده سلوان بالقدس الان الاعلام
الاسرائيليه يتحدث عن تحيد منفذ اطلاق
النار في سلوان بالقدس اذا الاعلام
الاسرائيليه تحدث عن تحيد منفذ اطلاق
النار في سلوان في همم القدس العالم
الاسرائيلي كان قد تحدث عن ضحيتين جراء
وعفوا عن اصابتين جراء في البدايه كانت
تحدث عن ضحيهتين وعاد بعد ذلك همم
ايضا يؤكد وقوع
اصابتين جراء اطلاق النار في حي سروان
بالقدس اذا خدمه الاسعاف الاسرائيليه نقلت
اصابه شخصين في اطلاق النار في سلوبي
القدس وهذه الصور التي نتبعه واياكم
لاطلاق النار الذي حدث في هذه
المنطقه همم هناك باستمرار طبعا عامل قبل
الجيش الاسرائيلي والشرطه الاسرائيليه
ايضا كذلك في حي سروان بالقدس وكما ذكرنا
كل هذه التطورات تاتي بعد ليله ساخنه في
مستوطنه النبي يعقوب البارحه
واطلاق النار المواجهات التي حدثت ليله
البارحه ضحيتها ثمانيه اشخاص وعشر وعشر
اصابات همم ايضا كان هناك لقطات لانتشار
السيارات الشرطه الامن ايضا الاسرائيلي في
ال- همم المستوطنه شمالا شرق لا قدس
استنفار للامن الاسرائيلي الان في محيط
همم سروال بعد اطلاق نار واصابه شخصين همم
هذا الصباح وقبل قليل ايضا قبل بدايه هذه
النشره كنا قد تابعنا معكم ونقله الاعلام
الاسرائيلي وهذه الصور كذلك ايضا
المتداوله لعمليه اطلاق النار في حي سلوان
في القدس استنفار من قبل الامن الاسرائيلي
اذا في هذه اللحظات في محيط سلوان بعد
اطلاق النار واصابه همم شخصين